In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxarion, for September 27, on which we commemorate, are venerable
Father Savateus, founder of the monastery of Salovky.
Saint Savateus was at first among at the monastery of Saint Cyril of White Lake, where he spent
a good many years early in the 15th century.
His virtues and ascetic struggles, winning him the respect and admiration of the brethren.
But wanting to obtain glory that comes from God and not from men, he departed further
north to the monastery of Valam.
Yet, there too, he felt the good opinion of men hindering his search for God, and to escape
the troublesome affection of his brethren.
He left secretly one night, intending to make his way to the uninhabited island of Salovky
in the White Sea, where he heard conditions of life were very harsh.
When he arrived at the coast to take ship for the island, everyone tried to dissuade him
from venturing to such an inhospitable place.
But full of joy, at having found at last, somewhere suitable for fulfilling his eschisies
in silence and solitude before God alone, he said to them,
My children, I have a master who has the power to renew the strength of the old, and to
infeable the young if he so wills.
He makes the poor rich, clothes the naked, provides for the destitute and satisfies the
starving with a measure of food, as he fed 5,000 men in the desert.
Then, as he awaited the season for sailing, at a retired spot near the river Vig, he met
Saint Yermanos, who was living there as a hermit.
Saint Yermanos confirmed everything Sabatios had heard about the beauty and remoteness of
the Isles of Salovky, and they decided to make the two-day voyage together in a fishing
boat, putting all their trust in the providence of God in the year 1429.
As soon as they landed on the island, they planted a cross in the ground and settled in
a hilly location, nine miles from the present monastery.
They set themselves to till the soil and converseed ceaselessly with God in prayers and hymns.
A family of native fisherfolk wanted to settle on the island soon after, but the fisherman's
wife was visited by two young men of shining countenance, who, striking her with bundles
of twigs, commanded her to leave the island with her family, for God had set it apart
for monks.
From then on, no one living in the world dared settle on Salovky.
After six years, Saint Yermanos went to live near Lake Onega, and Sabatios was left on
his own.
His ascetic feats are known to God alone, but nature itself in those parts tells its own
tale of all he must have endured, struggling against the bitter Arctic cold with burning
love for God.
His soul activity was prayer, and the contemplation of those good things promised to the elect
in the life to come.
When he was already old, fearing lest he depart this life without partaking of the holy
and life-giving mysteries, Saint Sabatios returned to the mainland, where he met Abbot Nathaniel
on the banks of the Vig, just as he was taking the Holy Communion to a sick man.
He asked him to hear his confession and told him how greatly he desired to receive the Holy
Communion, which he had been without ever since he left Valam.
After he communicated, Sabatios settled in a chapel nearby, and made ready to give up his
soul to God.
A rich merchant of Novgorod passing that way called in on the altar to ask his blessing.
And Sabatios taught him out of Holy Scripture how to lead a godly life and said,
spend the night here, and you will see the grace of God.
The next morning on the 27th of September in the year 1435, when the merchant entered the
saint's cell, it was full of a delightful scent, and the holy starets, who had passed away,
was sitting clothed in his monastic habit as if he were asleep.
The following year, Saint Yermannos accompanied by Saint Zosimas returned to Salovki and founded
a cinematic monastery that was to have a brilliant future, and where many saints would live
through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save us.